greetings Uncle Joey here it's Tuesday
the 2nd of January the checkin is
brought to you by on it listen hit's
been there with us for 10 years and I
love him from the Alpha Brain to the
shroom Tech to the shroom Tech immune
they have so many new products but how
do you know go to hit.com right now if
you see something you like press Coco
Diaz whatever and get 10% off tell them
uncle Joey sent you I forgot what the
code was seriously but it's either Coco
you know Uncle Joey or Joey you're gonna
get 10% off delivered right to your
house and it's a great way to start the
year with some Alpha Brain to get your
Tip Top Magoo get your focus back on to
help you be the best that you could be
speaking of being the best that you
could be this episode is also brought to
you by
fuji. g whatever fuji.com listen from
from day one I've used the Fuji G if
you're thinking of joining jiujitsu and
you're a little bit of a big dude go to
Fuji they got the ghee for you they got
a nice A5 a nice A6 the belt you'll wrap
it around your stomach like 14 times and
it still falls off why because you're
chubby like Uncle Joey g g g g g anyway
go to fuji.com tell him Uncle Joey sent
you
Diaz Joey Coco try off for of them get
10% off your first order on GES the
[__] gese are tremendous the superado
they got some geese dog light training
Gees that'll blow your [__] mind go
to Fuji right now and without further
Ado let's get this party started Jack
where's Lis Sayad at turn up your TVs
run for your lives it's over they didn't
put you on this planet just to give up
if Uncle Joey could do it I can rule the
world I you got to be
welcome back
[Music]
to happy New Year [__] we did it
another year it's crazy 2020 dude 12
years ago the church [__] crazy in
September
2012 20 [__] 12 it's been a long
[__] time brother but Happy New Year
2024 Happy New Year to all the people
that chump in with us one day a week
it's gonna be our year [__] this
morning when I woke up that's the first
thing I said to myself I'm I don't think
about years I think about like how I
feel and uh I'm ready I'm [__] let me
tell you something this is the hardest
holiday ever why I could live to be 200
I don't know like over like Christmas
Eve Christmas day I wasn't feeling it I
was [__] bored I uh I don't know I
don't know what happened you know I I
thought the year ended too quick I
wasn't done yet that's what I'm trying
to [__] say I wasn't done yet with
2023 and you know I was bored how can
the city close down December 15 you know
that was it I was just bummed because I
couldn't wait for
today well why today couldn't wait you
know how people wait for Christmas day
and they can't like last night I
couldn't even fall asleep I fell asleep
at
2:30 after that because that there was a
honeymoon [__] Marathon that started
11: oh nice I got home at like 5 after
12 and [__] started watching and my
daughter got home about 12:30 we watched
it till about 2:30 and when I woke up
this
morning it was like the people who went
on strike in La woke up when the strike
was over like as usual I woke up
enthusiastic I thought that they' beat I
thought the bluebird of happiness would
knock on my door with 25 G's today or
something I thought somebody would call
with a job but nobody called nobody came
over I didn't see the [__] mailman
thank God the Greek diner was open I got
up early and I went and got two [__]
eggs I didn't want to wake my wife up so
I went down and got some eggs you know
it was just uh one of those years where
I couldn't wait for the [__] holidays
to end you know like from
a a comedian perspective wait till you
start getting heavy into C see that's
the good thing about comedy it never
shuts
off right like I already saw ads this
morning for people who are doing big
weekends this weekend like they're
already out and [__] going full speed
they're [__] you know and I was there I
know exactly what that feels like but I
always like to since the beginning I've
always liked the acting aspect of
standup like it gives you a a green
light to act like and I felt like I
could have done one more show this year
that's
it is that I I don't know who I was
listening to I was listening to a
podcast and they they talked about doing
vision boards it was a well-known
comedian and I can't remember maybe Ron
funches but he talked about doing Vision
what's a vision board so I actually
ended up doing it uh I haven't finished
it yet I didn't he like some people like
print out pictures or just putting like
what you want like sort of like goals
but like visualizing it and like okay I
actually had I actually had my
girlfriend's two kids do it and they
[__] love they did like six of them
it was just cool like it was it was cool
to like is that something you're going
to put for next year like a certain
number of shows you want to
do well I would for me when I first
started trying to motivate myself when I
was a full-blown junkie I remember like
in 19 before I went to prison I had a
picture of a tester Roa on my wall and
I'm like that's what I want but I felt
that as I got into the books and like
Anthony Robbins and stuff I felt that
you have to write the path how you're
GNA get there anybody could tell you
they're going to be president of the
United States tell me how you're going
to do it I'm going to be a councilman
for two years that I'm going to run for
May I'm going to lose but then I'm going
to get this job and then I'm going to do
that and then I'm gonna bang my
receptionist and that's going to set me
back
it's it's it's that's what I like I like
going okay this year I'm going to do 300
sets even though in my neighborhood in
Boulder I could just get up 16 sets a
month that's if I did every Tuesday open
mic every [__] uh Mexican restaurant
that the margarita Place uh in in
Colorado at the time it's still there
they don't do comedy though uh the Irish
bar the Australian bar on Monday night I
was doing 16 sets I wanted to do 300
right now I'm resting on like [__]
200 190 or something I got to figure out
how to add an extra 110 sets and I
figured out that I I had to drive to
Wyoming you know I figured out that I
had to drive to [__] uh New Mexico
one
weekend
or you know whatever was onto the side
and guess what that's what I did even if
it cost me money to do those sets which
they always do I wasn't getting paid
right I always went I went out the GRE
more and next thing you know I was at 24
sets then I'm at 26 sets I can never
break 26 then I moved to Seattle and I
was getting 35 the first month nice you
know so I always want to see the work
you know I always want to see for me I
like the visual I like getting on I like
being on stage and them calling your
name not even like them going Joey Le
just got off the MC's gonna do an
announcement and then's gonna bring you
up and you go by the curtain and before
they even explode or laugh you're
hearing the laughter I do that yes we
all do that so I borrow from both
philosophies you know but that was
writing down stuff for me I still
believe in the power of the pen you know
so who the [__] knows nobody that's a
good because when I did it it would been
good to like think about more I did for
a little bit of it but like actually
plan it out like okay like I put down
one of mine was to to write 20
minutes that's easy like and and I've
just been slower my I don't know why and
I'm hoping I can write more but like I
did think about okay that's like not not
even two minutes a month I can do two
minutes a month well your notebook
should look like this I want to do 20 i
w to write 20 minutes every quarter
every quarter Jesus yeah you got four if
you listen if you
write 15 minutes a quarter you're going
to have an
hour you think about this now that I
know this I'm giving you one of the tips
I'm gonna write in the book okay by the
fourth year of
Comedy you should be writing an hour a
year did I do that I wrote about 45
minutes and at that point nobody was
watching me so I could save material try
it different ways and stuff like that
but this is my advice for somebody in
the fourth year of Comedy third year of
Comedy once they got their feet under
themselves they write and listen this is
all part of the [__]
drill you know I used to write when I
was on coke what a waste I'd wake up was
horrible
material but
uh if you write 10 minutes a [__] you
know 15 minutes a quarter for three
years that's three hours by the time
you're doing com your seventh year you
really have three hours even though
you're doing 20 25 minutes it doesn't
matter you're [__] stocking material
so when you do become a headliner you're
working with four [__] hours a week
like Steve McGrew Steve McGrew was an
amazing guy to work
with because he had four hours of
material Ask Josh Wolf when you see him
next time next time you open up with
Josh Wolf you work with Josh ask him
about Steve McGrew he's a comic from
Denver as I was starting he was blowing
up he was the original rednecker [__]
comedy oh [__] okay I've heard we've
mentioned him before oh he's a brilliant
performer a brilliant writer how he
didn't become the king of comedy I I'll
never know I'll never know it's one of
the greatest questions of all time but
that's was his claim to fame that he
unloaded on you I remember one week I
did a a week in Buffalo with him this
mother [__] had seven different hours
and did the dirty show and he came out
with 30 minutes of dirt that would made
me look I was
embarrassed [__] you know how how many
years was he in at that point he if I I
started in 91 and I finally got to work
with him in like 98 in Buffalo 97 we met
briefly we had the same friends in
Denver for
comedy and uh it was just amazing to
work with that f [__] gu it was
really and you know now remember I told
you in the book I'm going to write
regrets what I wish done that's it
that's it that's it and that was my
marriage to cocaine if I wouldn't have
been married to Coke I would have done
it that way but enough about me I want
you to tell me about your New Year's Eve
experience your first how many years
have you been doing
comedy I around four because I took a
year off with Co so I'll say four I
started in
2018 so I'm getting into my fifth year I
would say that's pretty [__] good Lee
I didn't do my first new year I was
doing comedy like nine years eight years
or something I got you know I'm the only
idiot that got robbed on every [__]
New Year's but anyway how is your New
Year's experience so it was just awesome
man I I got it offer it was the first it
was really the first time like a major
chain had offered me a gig like like
some like other Comics that brought me
in and I've done a lot of really cool
clubs but like this is like a like a
like a a chain of clubs this is the
first time that they asked me to do a
gig and it was New Year's Eve with Sarah
Colona which was because I produced a
podcast with her and Josh 10 years ago
and it's awesome that like it was great
to see her and it was just like I was
kind of bummed and in a like you know
not bummed but like when everyone was
posting these New Year's Eve shows that
they had I didn't have one and I would
have had a great New Year's Eve but like
it I don't know I don't even know why
but when you hear listen to Comics talk
like they like they hate New Year's Eve
but it's also like an honor to do a New
Year's Eve show is like a lot like a lot
of comics I think and so just for me
never it would be it would have been it
was an honor like to to do one and they
were it was three great shows in s like
I got to go to Syracuse it was a great
[__] weekend it was I was happy for
you thank you I I it brought me back to
when I got like my first New Year's and
how excited I was and how ready I
was and uh I ended up eatting the bag of
dicks but that's completely well you did
you did tell me I just knew the
excitement late oh yeah I couldn't sleep
I it just no that's what comedy is
about that's what it's all about when
you're actually missing sleep because
you know when you called tell the people
what I told you when you when I called
you like five o'clock and you were like
I'm I'm I'm getting ready to go now I go
if I know anything about Lee he would
have been there 4:30
already yeah oh [__] yeah you would have
a gig at eight you get there like at
5:30 I'm gonna go up there make his
field early and drive around and see the
town knew Lee was that anal that he was
gonna be an hour earlier to your gig
which is a great trait you know but
that's what I tell people excitement if
you're not [__] excited about
something it's not going to happen for
you there's so many [__] elements
that yeah there's hard work and there's
writing and there's going to classes and
everything but if you're studying to be
a pharmacist and you have no excite if
you're not [__] like when you ever go
to a pharmacy they're kind of like flat
people
pharmacist unless you know them for a
while like once you buy like medication
to get crabs then they you know what I'm
saying once they know you got a viking
problem they'll open up to you a little
bit is that from experience or just
something you've heard you know
experience that they're not the most
social people in the world except my my
pharmacist Christina but
uh you know there's no
excitement you know when you see
somebody excited they excite you they
excit a team if you're working with
plumbers and you're doing a Big Res a
big commercial job and I'm going in
there with three old farts and two young
guys and one of the young guys is always
singing and [__] torturing the old guys
about not getting no [__] with their
rotten wives and all this [__] at first
he bothers you but at the end he's gonna
tell you about [__] like what' you guys
do this weekend sit at home and watch
football with your fat [__] wives
this is what I did I got my dick suck
with an umbrella over my head and you
know they just tell you [__] and after a
while they they they'll show you the
posit you know something positive you
should come to a class with me on
Tuesdays it's [__] Boxing class or
something like that anything I don't
even know how we got in this
conversation the edible is kicking in
you know what I'm saying oh yeah I was
dying laughing thinking about someone
saying that like a meeting because I
have to go back to my day job tomorrow
and I can just imagine someone walking
in I got my dick sucked under
umbrella people lose their mind what are
you GNA do that's the truth you know
people want the truth and they don't
want to hear it they have a [__]
heart attack but New Year's like New
Year's it's just exciting man as a comic
listen my first all the way and I'm
[__] it took me 14 years to take a week
off you know right it took me 14 years
to take six weeks off by the third week
I was dying the only thing was I was so
enthralled in The Longest Yard when I
went to New Mexico there was no open
mics in [__] Santa Fe and I wasn't
driving to Albuquerque that club down
there is kind of
funky and I remember how I felt but it
was a relief because I remember that for
those for from nove uh from June of
whatever
91 to April or May or whatever June of
2004 there was never more than three
nights off even if I was
sick even if I was
sick I was getting rid of the
temperature to be healthy but I was
getting rid of the temperature because I
couldn't wait to get back on stage and
snor Coke it was all in the package plan
you know I'm saying right but that's
part of it and that's what that's why
I'm so excited on the first that's why
I'm so excited on
Mondays because you have to be excited
even if you feel shitty about your job
if you go in there with a positive you
know and not let alone when you get into
something that's yours you know people
say you know I got into this and it's
not working out well what did you do and
then you hear what you did and you're
like you're not excited about this
excited is you're not
home if you want to be in a band you're
not home you know Monday through Friday
Saturday you're not home you're coming
home from work you're taking a shower
you're eating a [__] bag of Cheerios
and you're going to that club to either
perform help out or be a spectator until
somebody throws you in a band or gives
you a tech job or takes you on the road
whatever it's the same thing with comedy
it's the same thing with being an artist
it's the same thing with being a
photographer you know you have to be
excited about what the [__] you're doing
you ever work with somebody and they
show up and it's like 15 minutes to get
going 25 minutes to [__] start
talking and you're like come on guys Guy
this is the [__] you do on the drive to
work but it's also like even just even
just in life like like I'm oh because I
I I notice it I think because I'm very
jealous of it I don't have like that
like I I'm I I feel like I'm a friendly
person but I some people just have that
like I don't whatever it is is just like
super positivity super
energy and like they can talk like it's
you a lot of times some like you can be
very quiet but you also have I think you
you can turn that on I love saying hello
to people it's when they want to have a
conversation I get
depressed you know what I'm saying like
I love saying hello to people I was I
was eating Saturday night I went to get
like a bowl of pasta at my spot and two
old ladies came in and the lady looked
over my shoulder she goes that looks
pretty good I took a the bread dish and
I put some spaghetti on I go give it a
try she
froze came back and she tasted it and
she goes nobody's ever done that you
know we don't [__] around here remember
the night when we when I tortured that
chubby girl at the steakhouse Christmas
Eve we went to the steakhouse in in
Burbank and the guy put us by the
bathroom and I said something to her and
she came out and she was like all
excited she gave me a number she got to
be like 65 years old well because we
were sitting right by the bathroom and
you would just bring up like start
conversations with everybody while and
it was like a group of older like some
guys were just looking you like what are
you doing but you got this group of
older ladies and yeah I think you you
have this thing with women it's not even
like you're hitting on them but you just
talk to them in ways like I don't think
she's ever been talked to like I don't
remember exactly what you said but yeah
she came out and like had a piece of
paper for you right or like a card what
was it I remember that though was Hyster
phone number she goes if you're ever
lonely or some [__] I was like what you
were right there I was like what that's
Chate cake and [__] [__] [__] oh Jesus
Christ that
cake but I I still I you know whenever I
think of New Year's I think of New
Year's 2000 I'm sure I did new years
before that I just can't remember I
probably did New Years at the store one
year yet like but I had never done New
Year's out and my gig was Miami which I
had just done that July for three weeks
and just leveled the room had a great
time
audiences were great and they wanted me
down
there on like the 28th or something but
I couldn't get down there to the 30th
because I already had a week in Michigan
I had to take a bus from Michigan to
Miami all right I pretty much get to
Miami on the
30th I get off the bus I take a cab to
where I'm staying it's a condo right
across the street from the coconut
Improv and I put my luggage down I'm
hungry and I need an advance and I need
to get a grandma blow so I'm going to go
over to the comedy club Monday nights
was African-American night I forget what
they called it sugar Mondays or
something I forget the host the host is
a great guy out of South Florida he has
like a whole circuit down
there and I get to the club they let me
in it's [__]
jam-packed and I'm not there five
minutes I look up and it's Madonna and
Chris Rock
everybody was in Miami for new
years's holy [__] all right I don't uh
Chris Rock went up I remember getting an
advance I remember getting a piece of
rock I remember going to the flapper bar
around the corner the swim bar and going
to my room and being enthusiastic about
New Year's Eve I got Coke in my system
I'm G to get higher my girlfriend was
down there at the time with me she
bought like a beautiful gown she thought
she was Elizabeth [__] Taylor you know
we were getting ready to do a great show
oh my God Lee first show I go up there I
went out there too
cute I went out what does that mean I
went out there too cute I was thinking
that I was in front of a regular Miami
audience but without knowing I realized
after the show that there a New Year's
Eve
audience the Miami Improv at that time
was 70%
Spanish and 30% everything else
on New Year's Eve it's 90%
Jewish hysterical and temper they come
down from uh West Palm Beach and they
dress up nice and the whole thing I went
up there and tried to be a little dirty
cute and talk
Spanish Lee I have no reason to lie to
you I lost him at the six minute Mark oh
and there was still 19 minutes on the
clock
Jack [__] you know that thing uh all
remember about that night is don't let
them see you sweat right they saw me
[__] sweat
Jack did you get him back at all or it
was six 25 when the second show came I
wasn't strong enough at the time to
overcome the beating I took the first
show I never redeemed myself I did
better the second show I made the
adjustment and kept it a little cleaner
and you know I was also it was a Twan
show
wow okay so I was the first thing they
saw I'm not the first thing you want to
see and I know this going in even back
then I'm not the first thing you want to
see and if you're running a club you
made a mistake
by putting me in that
position really on New Year's Eve it's a
different audience give me a a beautiful
woman a chubby woman give me a woman
with a dress on she'll do a lot better
than anybody else warm him up talk to
him a little bit slow him
down a guy with a tuxedo everybody does
that I want to see a woman I don't care
if she's an opera singer part time I
don't care what she does I want to see
her do 10 minutes and then bring the
gorillas
up
right and even then on new years's if
you start with a magic act you'll go a
long way even though while the magician
is on stage I want to be outside the
building I will not go in the building
until the magician is off stage I'll end
up like those people in rockchester last
night some terrorist will crash in cuz
terrorists don't like magicians either I
tell you that much I
love training camp right now they got a
people they hate Jews you know they got
a picture of
[__] whatever we talk magician
magicians yeah they don't like magicians
well that's another reason I hate Hamas
I love I actually like magic gets me but
I also love how much you hate it why I
don't know why you hate it so much it's
like a car trick and you [__] get so
mad one of the greatest jokes I ever
connected with and I didn't even look at
it that way was Jerry roach's joke about
doing comedy in Texas Arcana he opened
up for a magician at a bar okay did you
ever hear that bit it was one of the
best bit I ever heard and he talks about
that the magician went up on stage and
people started yelling blasphemy and
[__] uh the Bible and all this [__]
the devil was on
stage and uh I forget the bit I'm not
doing it any [__] whatever but that's
to I don't know I don't know I don't
know what it is with me and magicians I
just never clicked with them you know
what I'm saying the best is I got a war
war going on with a magician till this
what do you mean a war a war it's a
[__]
War this war started in
like
oh
1985 1986 that's how this is gonna last
long in the Hamas War this it already
has it huh it's like all 40 something
years old what you've had a 40y year war
with a magician
yeah
he even made a YouTube tape about
me so this predates comedy what do you
what happened with this magician you
don't remember that whole thing when
Jimmy Schubert was telling us that he
made a video and then I found it and
he's like I can't I can't talk enough
about jod Diaz he's the worst human
being in the world he robbed me you
don't remember that [__] I don't
remember a lot of the church all right
so I I gotta look I I vaguely remember
but but no I don't remember this video I
was 19-year-old gangster out of Jersey
I'm living in [__] snow Mass Village
Colorado and they gave me a job my buddy
was the head chef and he says to me Joey
you're a muscular dude you like steak I
go yeah he goes why aren you coming and
wash dishes on Tuesday I'll give you
[__] 10 pounds of prime rib and and
you could steal whatever you want on the
way home it only pay 75 bucks or
something I'm like yeah you know I did
it one day a week but then it was
[__] a great job I'm not I'm not
embarrassed to say had it I love
dishwashing I would get high I would put
music on the back and I would just load
up the [__] dishwasher and spray it
get nice and wet the whole night I'd be
eating I'd take breaks I was allowed to
go out and smoke reefer I came back in
if I wanted a lobster tail the D would
make it for me so I went from working
Tuesdays to like Tuesdays and Thursdays
then they asked me to come in the
daytime and prep one or two days a week
so I would go in there they were
training me to be a sue chef at that
time yeah I didn't know what was going
on I had an opportunity and I would go
in there two days a week but in the
daytime you're in there
alone so you were to go to the bar and
put ice in the soda and fill your own
soda this guy did a trick you know those
fans that spin
around the bar had ceiling fans all
around the place would pack up during
ski season it was John Denver's
restaurant what did you
expect
the thing would spin around all night he
would go up to the people and say I
could do a magic trick there was like
three magicians working the room oh [__]
great little [__] bar and they had
great food it was like a five-star
restaurant it's called the
tower
and every night the guy would go I'm
gonna put a he would come out with a a
deck of cards and I'll bet you whatever
you want that you put your money on top
of the card I put a thumbtack on it I
could throw it up and it goes up in
between the
fans if it sticks I keep your money dog
people would come from all over the
world and drop $50 bills $100 bills
there was no fives or tens there this is
1983 $20 in 1983 it was like a whole
[__] Chinese meal right
so I go in there one day in the
afternoon and I noticed that one of the
ceilings is
lower and I was athletic then so I would
jump up high and take like a 20 or a 50
off the ceiling every time I worked I
took like 50 $100 you know I would take
down 520s and [__] 250s $100 bill then
there was an area where it was just $100
bills I figured out [__] I don't need to
jump I'll get a [__] I'll stand on
top of a bar stool there was no cameras
then and I'd take like 200 300 it was
all going into my criminal bankroll that
I was coming back to the east coast I
was just
preparing this went on from [__]
November to like
January Jesus why would he leave it up
there huh why did he leave all that
money up there at the end of the season
he would take it down he break it up
with the other magicians oh okay there'
be like [__] 30,000 each [__]
magician and that was fine I ain't mad
at you but if you're going to leave your
money exposed you got people like me
walking around they have cameras in
those days they had nothing so for
[__] three months Lee I would go up
there and I whatever if I had a
broomstick sometimes I go in there and
make believe I was [__] sweeping [__]
I drop a yard stick
down one day I went back to New Jersey
and the end of the
theft so he he in his mind he goes this
guy disappeared you know so he wasn't
sure but now I go back up there in
85 and actually I go to the bar one
night and I actually pulled like a 50
off I'm just hanging out with like some
guys and I go [__] it I used to do this
all the time I took a 50 off and I told
somebody somebody was with me they
repeated it and then I left there I went
back to balen 87 I forgot all about it I
forgot about
it this is
[__]
2010 somebody comes up to me and says
that they went to the Magic Castle right
was a guy that was a big- time magician
in
Aspen and I said to the guy is his name
Doc and he goes yeah I go oh [__] he
goes that guy is great I go no no he's
great but I can't believe that guy's
still alive so at night I went home I
was living in Hollywood I went home and
actually called The Magic Castle and
they told me that this guy lived worked
there and his what times he would go on
and what nights so from then on every
time somebody told me they were going to
Magic Castle I'd say ask the doc and
tell Joey Diaz sends his
love okay and every time somebody would
go in there and go Joey Diaz sends his
love he' go tell them please to go [__]
himself he robbed me he robbed me for
thousands and they would go off on and
then I see the people week they go what'
you do to that guy J de he's [__]
furious he's old he's still [__]
cursing your name he's talking
girlfriend and [__] so we just this just
went on I just kept sending people and
the manager at the store goes to the
Magic Castle a lot so every time he went
he tortured the guy yo Joey di sends his
love yo Joey Diaz sends his love they
got then Jimmy then Jimmy Shu Jimmy shu
is the only magician that I love but I
would still bust his balls like if I
went to Jimmy Schubert's house and he
had the pigeons out I'd tell him to
cover him up I don't want to see no
magic [__] pigeons I don't think he
has pigeons at his house yeah he had two
white birds at his house always when I
first got that light and I would go why
do you have two white birds and he goes
I use those for my magic act magic act
you better put another line of coke out
there and tell me the story I didn't
know nothing about no magicians here oh
I [__] I love it so you ready for
this one Jimmy Schubert gets a job at
the Magic Castle okay and he's actually
there one night he doesn't know that me
and Doc got a riff he's standing next to
Doc one night and some guy comes in and
goes are you Doc and he goes yeah Joey
Diaz sends his love and Jimmy says his
whole body language just changed and he
ran into the back and slammed the door
and then he threw something at the wall
in there when he came out Jimmy said to
him what's going on with you and he goes
that [__] Joey de do you know him he
goes yeah he's my buddy he goes he's no
good he robbed my money off the ceiling
and [__] like that and now he has the
goal to send people in there and send me
his love
constantly why are you tormenting this
guy because he [__] started saying
[__] about me if you're that stupid that
you're going to staple your money to the
[__] ceiling guess what I'm gonna
take it and with that I'm gonna take a
break I gotta go to better help now give
me two minutes and we'll be right back
this episode of the checking is brought
to you by better help listen you don't
want to walk around another year half
who Bots walking around confused and
right now is the time of the year when
you're making resolutions don't forget
to give yourself some credit for the
great stuff you're already doing therapy
with better help is an awesome way to
change bad habit habits and celebrate
good ones all you do is take a quick
quiz on their website and better help
will match you with a licensed therapist
and if you don't love the first match
you could switch at any time no big deal
no questions asked better help is
totally online you can talk with the
therapist on a video call message or by
phone whatever works for you when I work
with better help I use the video chat I
want to see her and she wants to see me
I love better heal I was doing for about
eight months and listen I'm I'm a lot
better today work through your problems
with somebody who has been pick just for
you while sitting on your own couch on
your time celebrate the progress you
already made in
20123 and make 2024 a lot stronger go to
betterhelp.com and Preston Diaz d a z
today and get 10% off your first month
listen it's January you want to shake
off the mukia you want to be the best
you could be you want to be able to let
people know who you are and it starts
with talking to somebody sometimes
that's where
betterhelp.com
Diaz comes in but just start with
read take the online quiz see what you
think and that's it if you like what you
read give Uncle Joey a shot you know
listen I use these guys I wouldn't be
over here talking to you about them if I
didn't use them so go to betterhelp.com
Diaz get 10% off your first month listen
Happy New Year from the checkin to all
you guys thank you for always being our
backbone all right let's go back to do
what we do best we're back [__]
anyway no more talk about magicians I
got a little upset there you know what
I'm saying sorry it takes me back that's
my bad budy
no it's all right brother it was an
interesting New Year's though I expected
people to blow up in New York City
nothing happened you know they had the
dogs out there was a Palestinian [__]
March but they told them you come down
here we're just gonna [__] shoot you
that's it not not tonight take the night
off go smoke some [__]
reefer I feel that go away from that
[__] stuff you know I was talking to
a friend of mine the other day my family
and I go to this church I don't even
know if I want to tell you this story
because I don't know it might sound
wrong the first week of January but I
got to tell you anyway we go to this
church close to the house very nice
people the singer at the church is as
gay as a $3 bill and he thinks he's
[__] Yu Brena he's got the head do
the whole thing he comes out singing
with a scarf and [__] like that I would
tolerate it I go to with my family I
would tolerate it you know me I go to
the early Mass 7:30 I want to get it
over with and get the [__] out there
it's not like I go to church a lot I'm
not going to sit here and tell you guys
I go to church a lot this is four times
a year I get the urge and I go my wife
my daughter my if my daughter is an
usher you know then I'll go sure she's
only been an usher like three times this
year but anyway somebody said at was
talking at one of the parent functions
not really a friend of mine like a
person that i' say hello to an
acquaintance and I heard this guy say
the strangest thing which you know
automatically set me off he goes you
know I like going to that church but the
gay singer [__] bothers me now you
don't Meely I'm a [__] gay Advocate I
love guys banging each other in the ass
love all the whole [__] Eric roacher
Story Eric roacher for president you
know I've always loved it I don't care
what people do it doesn't bother me but
there's a time and a place for
everything I also grew up very Catholic
right he was saying that the guy bothers
him listen I go and I told him I go
listen I don't hate gay people by no
means I got two best friends that are
[__] gayer than a bonard cat I got
two nephews I I you know me dog I'm open
but everybody should stay their place I
mean this gay guy comes in and he tries
to sing opera and [__] I'm not used to
that I'm used to Old priest and [__]
nuns that smoke maror cigarettes singing
[__] whatever the [__] they sing on
Christmas Eve right or whatever they
sing every [__] Sunday you know now
this guy comes along with his [__]
olive oil voice and his [__] charm
you know like sinatr the Godfather and
he's out there like Glory Glory the
whole thing Meanwhile my blood pressure
is boiling I'll tell you what I don't
know a [__] decent gay guy listen gay
guys like to sing and I'm but I don't
know a decent gay guy that's singing at
8 in the [__] morning he's polishing
his [__] from the night before he's
[__] taking the chains off from his
ankles from hanging upside down I don't
want to see this guy in church singing
at 8 in the [__] morning there's no
decent gay guy that's up at 8 jumping up
and down singing Barber Stan songs
they're all up the next morning taking
the glue off the nut sack the [__]
candle wax off their [__] they're
getting ready for the week they they're
replenishing they're doing liquid IVs
they're doing [__] IV IVs they're
doing it all you know I don't want this
guy in my church singing I don't need
this [__] I I want a regular fat dude
who looks like me that can't sing I'm
Happy I'll even throw him the extra 20
to [__] stay extra and you know
whatever and I got nothing against gay
people but this guy's like one of those
gay dudes that thinks he's better than
regular gay dudes that's the other thing
like this guy probably hasn't had a date
in like three years because he I don't
like the gay lifestyle [__] you what you
need is to go on [__] Eric's website
whatever the [__] it was called more men
what was it oh boy a Hoy boys a Hoy get
picked up by some [__] UFC fight and
get [__] in the ass he won't be in
church singing no more at 8 o'clock in
the
morning you'll be out there living the
lifestyle you [__]
anyway no offense off the year coming
off the bat you know what I'm saying why
[__] around I had to come out of my coma
it's been [__] three years Lee and I
had to come out of my [__] coma man
over the holidays I'm living my life
wrong I you know what and here's the
thing for people sometimes when you're
living you think you're living your life
right okay sometimes it grows on
you I'm
not I've never and this is what I was
struggling this is one of the things I
was struggling with because I noticed
something over the holidays and [__]
before the holid they started I'm not
the type of
[__] that I wasn't cut out to be
home from 6:00 to 11: at night watching
TV right that that's 5 hours of my night
I don't have that I could watch the news
for 10 minutes I want to watch the
weather and I want to see what's going
on in [__] Israel I want to see who's
playing tonight everything else I I
could care less about you know I don't
watch an episode of [__] the show
with Kevin cner it's always [__] on
though yeah though there's been a
marathon on I could leave and they're
killing some Indian I come back later
and they're stabbing the same dude it's
the same I left and I don't mind I love
the show I think the show's brilliant
but I'm not cut out for that so I made a
decision I'm going against the cut here
the last year what I do is I go against
the cut little by little I make because
I know in my mind that baby
steps become big steps right
so that's why I went to the city for
jingle balls you know that's why Gomez
hit me up today when I'm going to do
Legion of skanks I'm going to have to go
in there on a Monday night and drop
knowledge on that [__] you know
I like I miss those guys you know right
I got caught up and trying to be this
dad that I wasn't I love her I give her
all the attention in the world I keep
the lights on for her and I'm here for
her we do things like we go to the mall
we go eat you know we do
things but I need a little bit of my old
life back I don't want what I was doing
before not at all I don't want to do
eight podcast a week or 22
shows I downloaded uh Open Mic things in
Jersey nice Monday through Friday they
also have like a Facebook page yeah
Absol every city does yeah and I was
looking at different things there's a
couple of them close to my house nice
you know and I'm going to start there
guys no schedule hit this place on a
Tuesday it tonight there was one but by
the time we get there it's an hour drive
45 minute drive it's by my house where I
grew up in North Jersey yeah you'll find
I'm excited for you yeah I just want to
go up and shake the rust
off no
money if I can't do 10 of
those then we're GNA [__] put up the
white flag and go we
tried we're moving on I'm going to join
the [__] a band as a drummer or [__]
start singing in Spanish that's it
that's that that listen if you can't do
that you don't want to do what you're
doing so can you explain that so like
let's say after five you're like I'm
[__] back and you want to maybe get a
spot at a local club would that count or
you want to or you're like listen I want
to do 10 open mics I want to do 10 open
mics I want to feel like I did I want to
feel like I did how you sounded on
Thursday right you understand me if not
if I'm doing it for a paycheck then I'm
not really doing it from my heart again
we're going back to the labor of love
right that's why I love Rudy SAR one in
fact I got to give that [__] a
call and wish him a happy New Year I
think he sent me a text two days ago
it's the truth he this is what I gotta
go through I'm excited by writing my
books do you have what do you want to do
this year
I I my goal is 20 feature weekends
that's my that's what I 20 what 20 like
weekends on the road that's easy you
could do that I would love to be able
it's looking like that I'm gone I'm off
the first week but then I have like six
straight weeks that I have shows and I'm
so excited but
it's by this time next year I'd like to
be able to like have like a full feature
calendar oh that's next year let's worry
about this year right let's Lo that's
why that's why I figured half let's load
up on the idea of the 10 minutes every
three
months and putting up and putting up a
seven minute video every 90 days 120
days you
know
uh you know one thing I'm GNA write
about in this I got like chapter nine is
one of the big differen between me being
an open micer and you guys being an open
micer is the influence of social
media and how much open micers anybody
at any level as a comic we feel we need
to be on social media and yes I agree
with you but as a comic and as an old
school comic I want you to work the
basics I'd rather you spend
90% on stand up you know wholeheartedly
I'm not wor like I told you I'm not
worried about head shots
you're worried about head shots after
two weeks you're in the wrong
Market you know because I could be my
own you know I could be my own
photographer Le I was thinking about
that I could just go to comedy clubs and
go whoa I can make you a star Joey D is
here I could take your picture right put
you in the database and keep rotating
your pictures as you change because
that's what you really want to do as a
actor comic you want to like my IMDb
that picture is 10 years years old ain't
nobody going to hire me when I show up
looking like this they're G to go what
happened to
him right [__] but it doesn't matter at
that age or at that level is what you're
saying for stand up for now nobody's
gonna call me and bother me for a head
shot right like I I I didn't get a head
shot till I moved to Seattle that was 95
that was four years
in where now Comics are worried after
two weeks they need a head shot there
was so many things and just
distractions and this is and I think I
already know what you're going to say
but I was talking about this with
another comic this weekend what is your
opinion on Fe like features and opening
acts having
Merchant the world is a rough
world and everybody needs to make a
living everybody wants to make a living
I was deterred me uh a [__] junkie
was deterred from selling merch in the
beginning because my roommate when I
first moved to LA I had a friend that
sold
merch and he didn't tell me about his
weekends he told me about how well he
did with his terrible videos selling
stupid t-shirts right he was making as a
feature act not even a funny feature act
he was pulling down a thousand a week
selling stupid stuff
but he had become a businessman instead
of a
comedian right you want to sell open up
a [__]
Bodega you don't have to go all the way
to [__] Seattle to sell [__]
t-shirts you
know
and I I just it just takes
away I'd rather you learn how to be a
[__] comic then worry about because
if you're going to come to me every
Tuesday and go dog I sold 55 hats this
week that said take a shot I'm happy you
need the money we all need the money but
I want to see what you're taking away
from you're not Jud you're not coming
back telling me Joey that [__] joke
that I told you it [__] worked oh my
God and I added a tag to it and I did
this and while I was there I talked to
the club owner in Cleveland and he told
me he was going to hire me next time I'm
here and I could just spend the weekend
at his house and then work the week and
I could save on a hotel that's not what
they were telling me
right they were they were the biggest
thing was their profit margin on the
merch and dog I'm a businessman but at
that level we don't need [__]
businessmen and I'm G tell you what
today I went for a ride this morning
when I got up early and my favorite
vitamin shop was open they're the best
people in the world they've been there
for 40 years they're part of a network
like uh if you need something you go to
this guy he'll tell you what doctor to
go to like he hooked me up with my
acupuncture where I've been with for
three years two years I went in there
today and he told me he goes we're
packing up at the end of the month oh no
yeah he goes it's not worth us having a
location no more everything is being
done so much and just mailing he goes I
had 25 customers that moved away after
the
pandemic and they still buy from me they
still call me all the way in Jersey and
they call me from Florida south Carolina
Michigan they're calling me from all
these places he goes since the pandemic
I go online once a week and talk about
something I've got 100,000 followers
that listen to my vitamin talk and they
all order stuff from me he goes I'mma
eliminate the $7,000 a month [__] yeah
and I'll do this out of my garage with
my son we'll redo the garage he goes I
could have a a garage look like [__]
Time Square instead of paying 7 Grand a
month for 20 grand my garage could look
like Time Square heat lights soundboards
the whole [__] thing you know that's
awesome my point is I always like the
website
sale okay it removes listen to what it
removes it removes the
contact between you and the person for
right now which you're not looking for
as an
MC because when you bomb as an MC what
do people say to you you did a great job
Pete you did a great job Lee and then
they look at the MC and they go oh you
too you did a great job I don't want him
out
there really I don't want him out there
I don't want him out there for his own
ego
interesting and you're feature act
there's a problem when you're a feature
act I know three guys who left La over
this problem what's that the people who
come up to you after a show and they'll
go Joey how you doing great show and
then they'll go hey Lee how you doing
man great show and then when I'm not
looking they'll bow into you and they'll
go we like you better than him right
people do that constantly I don't know
why
they I don't they know what they're
doing or if they just wanna you bombed
and they want to make you feel
better I knew a comic that came home
once and went off on me
this was like my younger brother I love
this guy with all my heart we haven't
spoken really I mean we talk online from
time to time you know he uh did this he
opened up for a huge
comic
huge he went from doing clubs to doing
[__] little
Arenas oh [__] okay and every Arena and
this guy was very talented and very
[__] funny and he could right dog
this [__] could
right and I knew he was he had this
talent but he didn't have the talent
that this other guy had this guy had him
by 20 years guy still around Big Time
comic the guy that I'm talking about
he's moved somewhere I don't know what
he's doing anymore but the particular
one guy just blew up at me one day and
said you don't understand when I open up
for him on the road half the audience
tells me I'm they came here from me
instead of
him and I I couldn't believe he was
saying this to me but then I had a
couple club Owners call me and go is
your did your buddy hit his head on
something did a safe fall on his head or
something he just called me demanding me
for five grand for a $1,500 week telling
me because when he opens for the big guy
people tell him he's funnier than
him crazy just think that was a sales
pitch what's that like that was his
pitch like people tell me I'm and this
is me and you knowing each other like I
worked your Club as an open micer and
now one day eight years later I get a
bug up my ass and I come to you and go
you know
what I uh went on the road with this guy
and even though you're featuring me the
only way I would come back is as a
headliner and you're like bro are you
serious yeah I've been on the road with
him for a year he does 10,000 people a
night you know 80 nights I have this
huge following and this is what you're
gonna pay me and he goes but I'm not
going to be able to sell that as a
credit I know a thousand openers yeah
come here and they've died because you
know and I remember myself when I used
to work with Rogan there was a period
when they would make me headline
Wednesday
Thursday oh that'd be awesome would
headline Friday Saturday
Sunday I would sell 18 tickets a
night they're not there to see me they
to
see did the club expect you to sell
tickets or were they just like they were
developing me they made so much money on
Rogan that they took a
chance they just let because I was gonna
feature there I was there all weekend or
me and with Co
headline right I remember those shows
yeah so it was always uh there was a
system
and I believe in that
system there a system and that's just me
I could be wrong who the [__] am I I'm
sitting in a basement doing a podcast
with you on a Monday night you know what
I'm saying what what do you do you have
a plan for the open mics do you like do
you have jokes you've been working on or
like what do you because it's you don't
really like five minutes is is it going
to be tough for
you I could I talk in my sleep for five
minutes well not that you can't talk but
that it's so short no five minutes is
perfect okay I just want to listen you
know what the best thing is when you run
in your house and your decision is
whether you want to pee or write that
joke you thought about on the drive home
that's love for something you
know there's a certain thing that you
get and don't get me wrong Lee and you
know this is true up to the pandemic I
worked harder than [__] I wrote I moved
my material around I overthought myself
sometimes with the process and the
process was a lot
easier you know but I always worked very
hard on material I always stressed to my
agents that I wouldn't go to the same
place every year just so those people
would not see me do the material even
though the money was there I wouldn't go
I'd rather go somewhere else that
Market's already built you saw me twice
in two years now it's time to spread my
wings and go write some new material and
come back to you in two years that's a
tough decision for a lot of comics I
know decision because I never wanted you
to see nothing bothered me more my first
two years working with an agent and you
don't know what AM my geography [__]
major I don't know what nothing is and
they would put you like in something
whatever Ohio and Columbus within 3
weeks Dayton Ohio and Columbus I'd want
to shoot myself in the
head because not the let's say you did
Dayton first right by the time you got
to Columbus it was the same people that
were in Dayton and you didn't know it
till Friday night you've already done
three [__] shows with that same
stupid
material and and you notice people who
were at the other
shows and that's why every show is
always different from me at least a
little bit the closer has to stay where
it is right that middle Arc has to stay
where it is but that beginning you could
jump a little around you know it's not
like I'm fighting to win them over they
already know who I am so there's always
strategies here you know what I'm saying
comedy's a strategy standup comedy is
always going to be a strategy and you
think about it whether it's a two-minute
open mic a 5 minute Open Mic or a 50
minute headliner routine or an hour and
a half headline a routine I have never
not you know when I call I don't even
call you before the show I call you when
I know you're there right it's that's
funny I know you're there because you're
a professional like me after you go get
that steak at two o'clock and you go
back to your room at 3:30 you ain't
leaving till game time you're like an
animal inside a room and they're just
like walking by with a steak you got no
clothes on and you're in a cage and they
just keep walking by with that steak and
you're like ah when I out of that room
at
7:15 when you're in that shower and you
try to bang one out and nothing comes
out because it can't excite you because
you're too excited for comedy I mean you
could have a girl in front of you and
you're trying to bang one out of the
[__] ddy and the next thing you know
baboom why because you're so excited
about the comedy you can't wait to get
out there and [__] kill
him and then go up there as them see and
I'd bomb because I would go out there
like an M they want to be greeted they
want to be welcomed I went out there to
kill him to tell him that that kid's a
[__] because he ate peanuts you
know it's a real joke I love that
joke [__] it's crazy it's really crazy
the
psychology behind the standup but I
don't want a comic from the first to
fifth year comedy to think about that or
sixth year comedy no to think about
writing material and going out there and
being the funniest they can every night
because I actually had that written down
because like I've noticed that's the
bottom [__] line as a comedian it's
the bottom line as an electrician it's
the bottom line as a weatherman no
matter what you do preparation is the
[__] mother of everything right it
right I mean it's the same thing in
everything guys you just have to make
different [__] adjustments you know
if I want to load trucks and be the best
loader I gotta be there at six in the
[__] morning or whenever the [__]
they load truck if I want to do comedy
it's tough enough that we got to come up
to life at 8 o'clock at night most
people get up in the morning drink
coffee and go to work at 8 we gotta [__]
him sometimes get a job drink go home
eat dinner with Grandma make sure the
dog is walk and then go do two sets
which you're on a list just there
wasting time you're not wasting time
you're watching your mouth is shut you
don't know nobody nobody knows you you
don't want to know nobody you're just
watching and observing the room and and
that's that's what doing it is that's
what being an open micer is and I want
that Feeling Again
Lee that's I didn't want to perform
without that feeling again the way I
felt at that theater in New York which I
love those people are [__] solid
people and I wish I fall in love with it
again so I could go over there and
[__] you know continue my commitment
I gotta fall in love
man it's funny that you just like you're
going to open mics to fall in love again
though because like open mics is rough
like they they can be great but like
they're also
rough to I don't want to walk into a
place where people want to take a
picture with
me I don't I don't want to walk into a
place that as I'm walking in there's 100
tickets sold and people are clapping I
got to make believe I don't want to do
that I want to pop into a place go can I
do five minutes get up there take two
pictures of the comics and tell them
listen just because you got a picture of
me on
Facebook doesn't do nothing you still
got to get up here tomorrow night and do
comedy at the pizza joint so there ain't
no [__] pictures I'm a communist
dictator right this I'm I'm I'm really
excited for you it's I I think it's
gonna be great I'm more excited about
writing a [__] book with
Erica I'm so excited about we start this
week tomorrow we're going to talk and
set the schedule we're going to go over
the outline of the book and I'm putting
what I tell you in a [__] book and
more like this is I'm excited about this
you know why Le [__] the story of my
life this is a book that every time a
comic wants to do standup this is one of
the books he'll read and I feel that'll
do better for me than any joke any club
I ever worked in my life but uh that's
what I want to
do I don't want you to walk into a
comedy club and see a picture of me on
the wall there's no comedy club that
even have pictures of me on the wall I'd
rather you buy the book 20 years from
now when you're starting comedy and go
wow this guy answer a lot and by that
time comedy will change again
you
know comedy really hasn't changed in
what is your opinion I guess I was
goingon to say I don't think going back
30 40 years comedy has changed too much
in theory like do you think it's I know
the parts have Chang but isn't it like
just open mic host feature headliner
like no I'm talking
about the evolution of a comic the way
the comedy scene has Chang remember when
I got into com I got into comedy three
months before Comedy Central started oh
[__] okay all right I got into comedy in
July of 91 when the rumor was that
comedy was on a low swing everybody was
waiting for Comedy Central for it to get
picked up
again okay Comedy Central was going to
really pick up comedy and it really did
a way it gave young Comics the MTV
Comedy Hour improv at you know you had
six or seven outlets for standup we
really don't have that no more we depend
on one and it's got to be their approved
standups you see some people that go in
but those are people who have great
agents I think that we're not for these
specials and whatnot we're not looking
at the right people we're looking at
people that have already been blown up
we need to find the people that are
looking to blow up like what Rodney to
do uh you know comedy has
changed in the last 20 years comedy has
changed in the last 10 years and comedy
has changed in the last five years it's
an art Le it's always going to evolve
like Jiu-Jitsu like [__] basketball
like [__] painting it's an art you're
always going to evolve you know
so comedy has changed I've seen the
difference but you know what hasn't
changed work enthusiasm
writing being
yourself that hasn't changed and that's
what we're talking about right so even
even in 20 40 years the comics would be
able to you know listen to that advice
and that's why like I I love talking to
you about it I love talking about it
because these last three years made me
remember all that and that's what I
wanted to do I wanted to take a breather
this to ask myself
what the [__] just
happened right you understand me that I
wish I could break this down for the
people at home and for young comics and
for anybody who listens to this [__]
podcast that I gotta tell you something
man I went into a coma when I was I
don't know
35 I was a struggling coma it was one of
those Comas that you ate at somebody's
house four nights a week with Joe Rogan
bought you a [__] turkey sandwich at
pink dot after the show and I just saw
that no matter what was going on in my
life I kept shooting on to that comedy
store right not thinking about then I
signed with a guy named Jeff gin and he
started get me to auditions right a
bunch of auditions everybody was saying
no no no no no then people started going
hey bring them back
in and then I wasn't getting the job
people started saying bring him back in
again
and then he
quit the managing business I had to go
with a different agent and all I started
booking but it wasn't because I just
grew overnight it was because of the
work Jeff gin had laid on for me do you
know what I'm saying so I forgot all
these things over the year one minute I
was living in a [__] apartment with
10 cats and next minute we're in the
valley starting a podcast in our spare
bedroom okay right then we went on a
[__]
uh in my world that was a [__]
blurb even when I wrote the book I
didn't really remember much after 2012
we went into a deep T we met the [__]
we because we busted out when the THC
stores were [__] blossoming like when
we started the podcast there was a store
on lanasham that gave away Bagels at 7
in the morning when you went in there to
get weed the Jewish guy Boris eigor
whatever he was a Russian
Jew you know I never went to that they
would give away a lot of [__] we had a
lot of Edibles we had tons of Edibles
that's what people understand it wasn't
that we were junkies is that [__] was I
remember doing a show with you in San
Diego to the American company and thaty
came out the company of the cookies we
used to eat oh yeah with the frosting on
top yeah I used to tell you they were
hundred but there were really 200 and I
would break them in
half they showed up and they gave us a
[__] bag of
cookies and we you know it was just a
different time we were at the right
place at the right time and next thing
you know I'm [__] uh doing a movie
with
Stallone I hadn't shot a good movie in
like five [__] years I st I started
telling people no I'm not doing that no
I'm not doing that I'm not doing that
for hundred bucks no more and all a
sudden Kevin Hart with with the [__]
Stallone movie and then next thing you
know I'm having a [__] kid the next
thing you
know we're moving offices you know the
next thing you know we're doing Assa
church with a 4our podcast with four
[__] animals in there you know Lee it
just went fat the next thing you know
we're doing [__] Matthew Perry dust
we're doing camine with our friend that
Sunday when I went home and watched the
[__] True Detective and almost had a
nervous breakdown and then we went
through the pandemic and next thing you
know I was selling out theaters and I
was about to [__] do Rogan September
at the
Garden and movie was gonna come out 2021
and that would get me longevity I would
you
know dog it all went push did I cry no I
knew it was part of the [__] game but
now let's figure out how the [__] did I
get
there like to me like when I was
listening to it sounds like almost like
a roller coaster like it just sort of
like took off at one
point and like you like you were just
doing the same stuff he were always
doing but then like little by little he
got busier and busier and we went to the
movies with a hundred people on
Christmas Eve I remember that yeah and
smoked dope outside the building and we
sat there for two hours and watch a God
awful movie I wanted to fold into the
[__]
chair you know we did all dog but I had
to figure out how I got there for me to
move forward I was [__] blown
away I was on the phone with people I
was talk people calling my house I never
you know I was getting emails from
people remember I wanted to see The
Mentalist you were you with me then when
I went I went for an audition for The
Mentalist right I think that's right
when we
started do you remember that that was
the I did Rogan a few times I went for
an audition for The Mentalist okay fight
like everybody else it's rough I get
there it used to be you went to an
audition there was eight dudes you knew
two of them I went to this audition
there was [__] 50 guys there all
reading for the same role and one of
them was Stephen
Bower you were reading for the same role
yeah we all were there was a bunch of
[__] Cubans gangsters Italians we're
all reading for the same [__] role
and I get there and step B goes how you
doing blah blah I go you mind taking a
picture I go no let's do it he takes a
picture of me I go you know what I got
my camera let's take a picture boom We
this is before the podcast this how I
got to know him not audition and we
started talking but we knew the same
people and next thing you know I go home
and I go look who I ran into for an
audition for The
Mentalist okay now I was going in there
for some I don't know a one line or
something like
that well that night I [__] get at
home and on in Twitter I got a message
it's like the executive producer and
he's like
hey what role are you looking to do pick
one and get back to me and me the
[__] that I am I read there was like
three roles that were bigger than mine
that I was perfect for but me I don't
want to ask I went with the role and he
goes okay report to the table read next
week and and it's because you posted
that picture on Twitter yeah because he
from Rogan when I got there he goes dog
you're great on
Rogan the story about the panties
something you know it was always
something like that that they saw me you
know I was watching this thing about uh
Bert Reynolds the other night
okay how he got Deliverance was some guy
watched him on a
[__] on a talk
show some guy watched him on a [__]
talk
show put him in Deliverance and
everybody was like you're wrong that's
the wrong guy and he goes I'm telling
you right now that's the [__] guy so
I don't know what the point of all this
[__] was but you know uh I just want
people to do it the right way if they're
going to do it right not that I did it
the right way but I always used those
three things we talked about I kept
writing we were talking about The
Mentalist yeah The Mentalist you pick
you pick this small role this what you
picked the smaller rooll I took the
smaller rooll and the guy gave it to
me and it was just oh because of that
that's crazy that's because of but for
years had a fight for Rose so every once
in a while you catch a break I don't
know what the moral the story was I
forgot I'm sorry what talking about like
social media up with a thousand
milligrams and today I did something
different
okay I had to switch up the bung because
I work with between three bongs okay
okay there's a morning one there's a
midafternoon one and then there's a
night night one all right do they have
names no no we night night is the
only I like night night you know what
I'm
saying uh but I want to do something
different on the first so I took the
reefer today and instead of grinding it
I cut it with a scissor my alltime
favorite I left a little bit more paper
on the [__] easy wider the thin one
and I [__] roll two numbers one of
some 36% [__] Texas T yeah and some of
some [__]
uh there was something else I got oh my
God 36% Jesus Christ 36% that Texas T
let me tell you something I think I
think you know what it is it's not that
you get more Stoner that you get more
hungrier you smoke yeah I was 36%
hungrier
yesterday a lot hungry I I I I I love
like freeze pipe I love them but I I I
especially like quickly like I the joint
is a little is fun no for me I got to
switch it around that's all I but I I
don't like sometimes I grind the [__]
reefer that don't work for me I got that
separates that THC I'd rather cut it
with a scissor very thin leave it chunky
and roll that it's a thicker joint but
it hits you
better you still dry it huh you still
dry it out I la in La you have a heater
I have like three different things and
then I rotate them and there's a certain
can that I use that dries it out real
quick it's and I put it in a wooden
drawer so it dries it out real quick and
then I move that batch but at the same
time I got three other ones
drying like I even I never even saw you
with a grinder I remember you would just
do it with like your fingers like it
would be that dry
well that's then then somebody gave me a
grinder and I figured out I liked it but
then I had to go back to Colorado
1983 snow Mass Village you know what I'm
saying cutting it with a scissor and
[__] inhaling that [__] like
I own the cigar
shop
yeah I love it
buddy all right what do you got this
week this week I'm off uh this Ive just
have open mics every night my next one
is I'm opening for wolf at the Richmond
Funny Bone the second week of
January you know what man you're [__]
beautiful I'm proud of you I have no
idea where I'll be I'm just making a
surprise
attacks uh and that's it I'm really
excited you're starting up again and
that no no matter what happens but it
just I guess the last question I have I
need to change [__] around ain't nobody
going to give me a job in n is a
security
guard you don't want to be a security
guard I know every once in a while I
look at the One ads and I look through
for senior jobs like you know those
dudes at [__] Co Costco but then I
went somewhere the other night and I
drove by Costco and I saw some guy with
a [__] bundle on his head walking
through the parking lot and I'm like you
know what I can't take that job either I
need like a cushy job like welcome to
Chick-fil-A
Sunday's off
part-time a food
allowance they don't give you a food
allowance no you get a card like Lisi at
needs $200 a month on a card on a
Chick-fil-A Christian card I know I know
he's Jewish but you got to make
exceptions to make the the machine run
smooth from time to
time I love it I hope well I hope that
doesn't happen what's that that you that
you decide you don't want to do comedy
you want to work at Chick-fil-A like I a
greita for some good money I'll go
anywhere Steakhouse how you doing vote
for me Uncle Joy what should I eat
poison that's what you should eat
look that would actually be funny to
see what i e poison you know something
like that like a [__] a Rayos or
Cuban restaurant that's big time maybe
I'll go over to Victor's Cafe and try to
bring it back Buy into it or something
play the Conger drums on Tuesdays
whatever it takes just something to you
know Jesus Christ I didn't even know you
played the Congress I don't want to go I
did have a very good and you know me
guys I tell you the
truth I did have a very pleasant
experience on jsx out of
Westchester the drive from Westchester
from where I live was a little long that
day but let me tell you something guys
for the extra deuce and not waiting in
the airport for 2
hours I stand behind it I even went
online and I saw some negative reviews
and I was like [__] you know I let me
give it a try and I gotta tell you
something both there and
back on time just bring a sandwich
that's all I'm telling you they give you
like sweet potato fries that's not GNA
fly when I'm 3,000 greet up in the air
and I'm starving and I'm coming down off
a [__] edible or some maluki I smoke
you know what I'm saying so bringing
sandwich how so you would just got there
like how long before the
flight uh the first time the flight was
at 5:30 and we got there at 10 after
5 and can you can you park right there
right there well Westchester they
suggest you get dropped off or an Uber
because sometimes the lot is two packed
okay let me tell you something when you
land in
Nashville Scott onam listen you know I
get anxiety if I see a long walk
especially after a flight I can't my
lungs freeze up or something I can't
breathe you get off the [__] plane at
50 yards tops to the
place you walk in they greet you and all
of a sudden your luggage is right there
you pick it up and here's the beauty you
just give the lady a name and she gives
you a car key and something to sign your
car the parking lot is Tiny you're not
walking the parking lot B you don't got
to take a train with this [__] guy
that looks like he's missing an eye
nothing you walk out there your cars
turn down and your trunk is open okay
summertime they got the air on and if
it's winter time they got the heater on
do you follow me dog and it was a de
more not even the fly there was five if
I would have taken them on United round
trip it was
560 okay on this it was 600 bucks 610 or
something like that that's worth it it C
you know I called the car service to
drive us to the airport they wanted
1300 you know I mean
1300 1300 you people got some bare balls
how long of a drive it's an hour and a
half that's a lot of money for an hour
and a half yeah and then I tried Uber
but Uber don't have the whatever so I
wanted Uber XL
like
doctors how was it like a lot
less
yeah 100 bucks or something no no no no
the difference
was 900
bucks wow cost wise me you know I like
to tip the dude he's in the car with me
for an hour and a half he's going to
have to inhale a fart at some point I'm
GNA have to scratch my feet like John
Candy and [__] train
PL you know I'm leaving some fungi
toenail dust in there in the front seat
or in the back oh that poor guy I would
have loved to have seen that oh yeah oh
yeah and then you know if they have
sometimes the driers pick you up and
they got the ear plug in they're talking
to some guy in [__]
Kuwait and I start asking creepy
questions and [__] like when H you
talking to me hold on no no and I
confuse him make a you know what I'm
saying
like oh I love it oh I love you buddy
2024 is gonna be a good year man it's G
to be a financial rough year you know
like people gonna [__] struggle this
year it's an election year God knows
what's going to happen in the Middle
East you know and if you don't think
that has something to do with you it is
I guess there's no champagne next year
why because the rped froze or something
like that and they can't make enough
bottles of it so champagne's going to go
up to you'll be drinking malt liquor for
[__] $100 an ounce next year and [__]
like
that that sounds
disgusting well like I have no I had no
yeah it's gonna be [__] up but like
does it affect you now like does it
never used to like I I'm surprised to
hear you talk about it what's that like
just like you know like current events
what what you know because you watch the
news in
La I used to watch all that stuff you
know what man
uh we don't have interesting current
events anymore like they're all like
either nothing you could even put humor
to anymore it's so [__] pathetic like
there's nothing you could even dog trust
me I know how to add humor but ain't the
humor [__] want to hear right
now you follow me you Ste me you know
I'm saying
so uh it's kind of weird like I don't I
don't know what's going on tell me so I
could you know I don't the [__]
Detroit Lions got robbed the other night
I know you know yeah I know a lot of
things you know I just don't know what's
relevant anymore because no matter what
we're going to talk
about there's 18 sides to a story now
you know but it's great you know I never
believed in you ever turn the TV on at
night at
7:30
7 o'clock turn the TV on it goes from
the news
to and they have on now like five of
those and the opening story on all them
is the same thing it's just their take
and I appreciate that but sometimes I
don't know what's going on I don't want
to give it a take I know what I
initially feel like I saw a baseball
player was having a relationship with a
minor today in what did you expect
they're animals down there you know it's
Miami he's Spanish she's Spanish you
know she know ablo he know
ablo
Jesus it's not gonna be good you follow
me holy [__] that that's so [__]
crazy he he he he didn't show up to the
whatever who like the pro that player
like didn't show up to court or
something right no he's back in [__]
Tijana he's he's done his name is he's
changed his name three times already you
follow me you're going to need the FBI
Homeland Security and [__]
investigator to follow him and by next
week he's GNA change his name another
five
times [__] those Spanish people are
slick they just keep moving it's 10
I you get in the computer we got him as
Lis we got him as Joe you got nothing
he's on the Run he's got your chasing
nine [__] people nine Spanish guys
that last name Hernandez how you going
to [__] figure this
out I love when you used to tell me
there'd be like 800 leasi ATS in Mexico
when I was when I was dating my ex
family took your wallet it's all over
the place you're like the [__]
detective that walked into Mexico with
the cat and they took his ID piic and
they sent it to the narcos you're like
open [__] season down there if you go
down to that border right now right
there's 10 Lei waiting on line and I
guarantee you not all r a Mexican
there's got to be one like a [__] you
know sold it to more people what they
sold my identity to more people now well
look what's coming
in there like 10 Le that' be [__]
crazy you don't you ever go to like a
phone pay phone in New York City right I
come up to you excuse
me excuse me you calling long distance
why what's the problem I want to sell
your a calling card it's the same thing
if you're walking towards the Border
like hey how you doing let's go in this
[__] first class how would you
like to walk in there as an American
right now give me the small T I know I
know it's hidden under your
foot why don't you take it out those
sneakers been on for 30 days
straight take it out [__] wipe the
rock whatever the [__] and then give me
the $10 I'm gonna give you a new
identity a social security card and
insurance for your [__] car when the
United States government gives you a
brand new [__]
Cadillac they're G to give me a Cadillac
yeah they're going to give me a Cadillac
but you're going to need a
name if not you're not going to be able
to drive for 10 years 10 years I got to
keep walking man we got an ID for you Le
at and that's
it right now there on the border going
how many [__] lisad gonna walk in
here they're all [__] taller than me
too [__] [__] I'm proud of you
for new years's I know you how hard you
work brother Budd Chit Chats we we have
[__] help because it makes me [__]
find some answers like I said I haven't
been [__] you know we wrote a book
together we did a bunch of [__] it's not
like I've been sitting at home in a
[__] uh padded wall I'm living my
life I'm trying to be a dad I just
thought that the way it ended before I
didn't like what was going on with my
comedy you know I didn't like what was
going on a lot of
things and that's why the pandemic came
at a perfect time and now I'm a
different person so we got to [__]
sit or get off the [__] pot I say it
to people now I have to say it to myself
you know what I'm
saying now if you don't mind I gotta go
drink some water and need a little
mushroom bar to watch Texas against
[__] Washington I think that's the
game that's coming on
so I love you buddy it was great to see
you I love you [__] happy New
Year congratulations and uh hopefully
I'll see you in a few weeks I'm so I'm
excited to be down there and I'm just
excited that you're doing it man you're
I know you kept saying you were retired
and I I didn't push no I wasn't retired
I never retired I was semi-retired I was
taking a breather I was
semi-retired so but I'm just happy that
even if you just do it an open mic a
week because I love watching you do
standup so I'm Havey your back work out
for me too I got other plans I'll give
them to you as they come along my
brother you guys thank you for watching
have a great week and now for a word my
bad [__] sponsors stay black
welcome back
[Music]
to all right the show is over guys thank
you for listening it's the first of the
year I hope Lee and I both wish you a
very very very happy New Year how many
times have we said this to you in the
last time years a [__] lot guys so
anyway what are we talking about here I
want to talk to you about Fuji G listen
you're thinking about changing your life
you saw the the chick last night the
stallion on the show you're like I'm
gonna go join whatever the listen you
want to have contact with people you
want to talk to people you want to grow
into a family go to your Wikipedia I
don't know Wikipedia whatever Google the
local Jiu-Jitsu school in your area take
the free class see what it's like if if
you like it go to Fuji g.com right now
pick a nice ghee out the superado they
got GES for under 100 bucks that'll rock
your world they even had a guon special
for 60 a couple weeks ago that'll rock
your world it's Fuji Jack they got the
mountain the whole thing there Earth
anyway it doesn't matter go to fuji.com
and get yourself a ghee and like I told
you either use
cocoa sorry Uncle Joey Joey whatever
take your pick take a chance Columbus
did also I want to talk to you about on
it I've been with them for what 12 years
now Lee 12 years and every January I go
on my little Alpha Brain [__] cycle I
blast off for four weeks I drink water
tomorrow I gotta go do a blood test but
what what am I telling you all this for
just go to honor.com that's where the
party starts they got shroom Tech they
got shroom Tech immune they got
electrolytes they have so many great new
products that'll rock your world but it
starts with you go to hit.com right now
and again take a chance Columbus did go
with Coco Uncle Joey or Joe Joey it's
Joey for on it all right anyway they
don't have a website that helps you
recover like you know you miss podcast
cues anyway I love you guys thank you
for giving us a chance again on the
first Tuesday of the year we'll see you
next Tuesday Morning Tip Top Mago stay
black